let's go next to our caller from the
8:02 area code is ATO to Vermont if I
remember correctly yes it is yep
who's this Kayla hey Kayla what's up I
was wondering if you had seen the
Twitter feud between Kyle kolinsky and
jank youger about or Jenks basically
posted the lesser of two evils argument
with Biden and then added that you're
not morally superior if you decide for
your own principal reasons or whatever
not to participate in the presidential
vote like and then Kyle said does that
mean I'm morally inferior and Jake said
yes I did I did not see that I did not
see that Kayla I can still comment about
the idea of it but I have I'm gonna I'm
gonna reveal something to you Kayla that
I have kept secret for about five or six
days twitter has become so toxic for me
that you have not looked at my replies
other than verified replies for five
days I have not I just
I'm tweeting and I will check my
verified replies which I know is like I
know it sounds elitist but I need some
way to kind of reduce the toxicity of
Twitter and then I'll look at the things
I'm following I I have not looked just
as a test for five days I've not looked
at my general replies feed emotionally
Kayla I am doing so much better can you
imagine that yeah I don't you really use
Twitter that much either in your Kyle
even says that he hated that like the
fact that he got into a Twitter feud in
the first place but the interesting
point behind the argument is the voter
shaming that's coming from a lot of
people on the left right now who have
decided that they're going to vote for
Biden whether or not they were
progressive or not and Jamie shaming
people with views like Kyle's which is
you know Biden doesn't mean his
standards you know war criminal like
universal health care these are
principal things and because of that
he's not going to participate like is
shaming them like worth it
yeah I don't think so here's my view
unless actual voter shaming I don't
think is worth it
explaining why you think someone's
calculation is wrong I think is
completely legitimate and the problem is
that the line between voter shaming and
explaining why you think someone is
wrong can be blurry sometimes it's not
blurry but an allegation of voter
shaming can be made to shut down a
conversation now I didn't see this feud
between Genk and Kyle both of whom are
friends of mine so you know it's hard
for me to say specifically whether it
was over-the-line or on this side of the
line but I agree it's most importantly I
don't think voter shaming will work and
that's one reason why I don't think it's
a good idea but explaining to someone
listen the five things you've said about
why you're not going to vote for Biden
to me they seem kind of like BS if you
just prefer Trump say it and then I will
respect your decision much more but
concern trolling which were sometimes
seeing exaggerations of Biden's of the
flaws were sometimes like let's just be
honest and I wish some people would just
straight-up say either because I think
he's better or because I think it would
teach the DNC a lesson I prefer Trump
just say it and I'm not saying Kyle
believes that I want to be clear I would
respect the people much more if they
just were upfront about that like if you
give me these choices I actually prefer
Trump cool okay we do have anyway yes
like are they referring like if you're
not making the choice are you saying
that you prefer Trump necessarily not
necessarily but so here's here's why I
have been repeating this idea that not
participating isn't neutral what I mean
by that is Trump won and is the
incumbent incumbency comes with you
power it's tough to remove an incumbent
president so merely not voting you might
say well it's not helping anyone well
when you consider the power of
incumbency opting out
you could argue actually helps the
incumbent that's sort of like one
argument the second argument for why not
voting arguably is beneficial for Trump
is I'm talking specifically to a lot of
the people who say I'm on the left and
don't like Trump but I'm still not going
to vote those folks are folks who
specifically have said I don't want
Trump to be the president and aren't
voting so they by virtue of not voting
are helping Donald Trump if you have
people who are on the right and choose
not to vote of course they're helping
Biden there's no doubt about that so
when I say not voting isn't neutral and
it's beneficial to Trump it's number one
because I'm speaking to my mostly
progressive audience who I believe
doesn't like Trump and number two
because the power of incumbency does
make a non-vote on balance more
beneficial for the incumbent yeah yeah
all right all right Kate
we're in Vermont are you by the way yeah
I am I've met Bernie several times no
but what part of Vermont I'm in Central
Vermont are you from Montpellier
Montpelier oh very nice I stopped
stopped there last time when I was
driving up to to Montreal had a great
sushi lovely you don't think of
Montpelier as the place to get sushi but
I got some great sushi there weird I
don't know where to get sushi right well
today it might be a tough day given
what's going on Cayla
I really appreciate the phone call yep
thank you all right take care